[ __ ] was hot let's just say [ __ ] was hot
i mean the bay high period yeah just
like detroit like vallejo richmond san
francisco oakland all that [ __ ] turned
up yeah right now i feel like the bay
right now is kind of like nationally got
a really bad rap because when we see
a lot of the smash and grab [ __ ] when we
see a lot of the um you know homeless
fools going up into the walgreens and
just filling their bag with [ __ ] and
walking it's all because you know in san
francisco like i'll go there once a
month you know for empire [ __ ] and
um
the walgreens like in the city and the
cvs's are closed
themselves
i don't think it was like
a bad rap like i feel like like well no
because i think in sam in in the city of
san francisco
they got that law
that they can't stop you and the cops
won't prosecute you or arrest you if you
if you shoplift under a thousand dollars
so that's why
so all the petty staff [ __ ] so you'll
see all these dudes going in on their
bikes just [ __ ] rolling up in the
[ __ ] cvs they just did like a smash
and grab out here for like they did at
beverly hills five million or something
yeah that [ __ ] was crazy did you see the
video i just heard about it oh the video
is crazy
like yeah i'm like damn he's doing that
[ __ ] everywhere i was just that no the
smashing grab shit's everywhere was at a
jeweler in vegas and they told me that
they just came in there and did that
[ __ ] there too that's where it kind of
sucks like if you're in california
like because you can't really like
you know some people pull some [ __ ] like
that in florida they're getting smoked
by the owner yeah california you
probably
who if you shoot the guy yeah you're
probably gonna go to jail before he goes
to jail yeah it's crazy like that's just
the gun likes and [ __ ] the gun laws and
[ __ ] i think it's gonna i think it's
gonna chill out man
in in cali because i feel like people
are starting to realize i think they was
doing all that [ __ ] because like the
like they was uh protesting right
it was just protesting for some somebody
somebody got killed or something well
there was the george floyd protest yeah
june the 20th day was doing all that
[ __ ] of that too yeah it's been crazy
man cali's been a crazy place the last
couple of years um
and then yo
so you know the one thing about the bay
too that everyone is uh that's
synonymous with the bay right is bipping
bippin is kind of like um there's you'll
go to the bay and there's people who'll
just leave all their windows down
not even when you leave the window down
you know
don't come through the window but i'm
saying they'll leave the windows down
because they're like i'd rather you just
come into my car and see there's nothing
in here then you break my [ __ ] window
and i have to replace it yeah
yeah okay cool yeah uh
it actually happened to me not to me
personally but uh roc nation had came to
oakland um
they was trying to sign me and um
the guy had i went to get something to
eat and i told him like
be cool like
and they they went up the street and got
something to eat and like when they when
they walk in the store they hit their
[ __ ]
it's crazy crazy like but um
a lot of rappers though like they come
out different empire they always getting
their [ __ ] hit i got a lot of rappers
and got they jury took out the air and
all type of [ __ ] i think
it's very easy to spot a rental car
um i mean we if you in that profession
yeah yeah yeah if you're in that
profession if you are not
you know what a rental is for sure yeah
it's crazy because we we was just
driving the other day
we're downtown oakland we like that's
the bippers right there and they're
driving around in the cars just doing
the circles you could just you could
just knew we knew they called you know
what they're doing